now you do give us some information but
you got to go a little further so what
you do know already is that you define
these points right and then you have
these three much mutually perpendicular
edges right leg a length B now I'm not
gonna put the seat on there just yet the
reason why is because when you're
working this and you're gonna go and
work out the area by similar
cross-section it is in your interest to
know what this distance is
and what this distance is
okay now remember the origin is down
here the origin is down here right so
therefore the further you go up away
from the origin on the x-axis the
diagram even tells you that yet they say
see the legacy lies along the x-axis
therefore this distance in here what's
it equal to that's a variable X right if
I went right down to the base to be x
equals zero that'll be a triangle if I
went right to the top where there's the
point that the x equals C right because
that's X which is variable right that
now tells you what this distance is
right if the whole leg right the whole
de jure C and that's gonna give you C
minus X there okay a lot of you got
confused because you are not sure where
X was somebody put it up here or you do
it was just very confusing okay your
diagram diagram now where the monks
well again I need to be able to talk
about the sewer triangles that are here
you didn't have to prove that that was
similar save by inspection if you like
go for it you're an extension too soon
okay but you still have to provide
reasons okay so for instance if I call
this cross-sectional triangle the
variable what if I call it P Q R right
you at least needed to say there are
some similar triangles here right so for
instance in my case I would say looking
okay because what I'm really interested
in is gonna be this and this right
because they'll give me the area of the
cross-section um I talked about these
two triangles AOC triangle a or C that's
the big one right and it's similar to
triangle
qpc okay now the real reason is they're
creating your line and that's very easy
to see because you've got all those
parallel lines corresponding angles so
on I did let you get away with it if you
said by inspection but I did not let you
get away with it if your next line down
here and no letters might be slightly
different but on my diagram I would say
something like this the vast majority of
you left out this line didn't say it
started here right and then you said by
similar triangles that is not a
geometric reason right the reason for
this statement is that what are these
things for a DS then corresponding sides
in similar triangles so you need to say
at least corresponding sides are in
proportionate or something right like
they're not angles it's the what the
property are you talking about okay so
this this is not sufficient okay you
actually had to put the fourth pinion
bear now eventually you then after this
you get your actual values which you see
on the C minus X that P cube is the
distance I won so I rearranged okay now
because the proof is literally identical
for rather than this pair of triangles
it's that pair of triangles okay you can
say similarly because all of the
reasoning is identical okay so I want P
R and that's going to be B 1 C right all
right
okay there you go so there you go those
are your two perpendicular edges of my
cross sectional area area equals heart
base height and then you get to the
given result